Absolutely everything you think about yourself
and the universe could be an illusion.
As far as you know, you are real and exist in
a universe that was born 14 billion years ago
and that gave rise to galaxies, stars,
the Earth, and finally you.
Except, maybe not.
You may actually not exist for real
but be the dream of a dead universe
– you and everything you think exists.
Crazy as it sounds, this may be an unavoidable consequence
of our best scientific theories about the universe.
Ok, this is a bit much – let’s start at the beginning.
We need to understand three concepts
for this idea to make sense!
1. The Arrow of Time
What distinguishes the past from the future?
Put a drop of red ink into a glass of water
and you see the ink spread until it fills
the container but never the opposite:
colored water where ink spontaneously concentrates
and becomes a drop at the surface again.
Time always seems to flow in the direction
in which the ink spreads.
But if you take a microscope, all you see
will be a swarm of molecules colliding at random
– there are no rules, no forwards and backwards.
Every individual motion that happens can occur in reverse.
But we perceive a sort of arrow of time
that makes things happen in one direction
– how does this phenomenon occur?
Well, this arrow of time is not actually fundamental,
but a matter of probability.
When ink molecules spread to fill a glass,
there are many different “slots” of space they can occupy,
and therefore many different possibilities to combine them.
And just like your chances of winning the lottery grow
the more tickets you have,
the probability that ink molecules will end up
filling the glass is much higher
than the probability that they'll concentrate in just one spot.
So it is not that the ink forming a drop again
is forbidden by the laws of physics, it's
just extremely unlikely.
To see it you’d have to wait about 10 to the power of 100,000,000,000,000,000,000,000 years
– a 1 followed by one hundred sextillion zeros.
If you had this much time to spare, eventually
by pure random chance, you’d see a red blob
form again. Actually, with enough time,
you could see any shape forming. Like, for example,
a small, red, soggy brain.
Ok, let’s move on to idea 2.
2. The far future of the universe
Our universe was born 14 billion years ago
in the Big Bang, it expanded and evolved
to give rise to the myriads of galaxies and things.
In other words, the universe is kind of
a glass of water with a lot of ink doing
stuff – it has an arrow of time.
But the universe is not a static glass, it
seems to be getting bigger at an ever increasing speed
because of dark energy. Basically, everything
in it is getting more and more diluted.
In about 100 trillion years, the last star will
die. Then few interesting things will happen
for the next few decillions, vigintillions
and googols of years.
Eventually the universe will be a dark place
fully dominated by dark energy
– a rapidly expanding ball of pure space
almost devoid of matter.
You might think that this would lead to the
ultimate death of everything
but dark energy
has one last surprise for you.
In a universe dominated by dark energy, space
expands so dramatically
that it creates a "cosmic horizon" around you:
a border beyond which nothing will ever
be able to reach you, not even light.
So for every practical purpose,
the universe has become a glass of finite size
about 36 billion light-years wide, surrounded
by an impassable cosmic horizon.
Such a universe glass is basically a giant black hole
turned inside out.
We know that, due to quantum effects, all
black holes emit a tiny amount of particles
– a phenomenon known as "Hawking radiation".
And so does our inside out black hole.
In the end, this radiation will fill the universe
glass with particles again.
At this point, so far in the future that giving you a number
has no more meaning,
we've reached the true final state.
The universe has now become a closed box
full of particles at an extremely low but finite
temperature. And since they have a temperature,
they undergo random motions. Or in other words:
a glass filled with water and ink
and an infinite amount of time ahead.
Things are about to become interesting again.
3. Typing Monkeys & Fake Universes
Eternity is a long, long time.
So now even the most extremely unlikely things can happen.
The fluctuating particles are bumping into each other
over and over and over again
creating every combination of particles that's possible.
They're like a monkey typing at random on a typewriter.
Almost all of the time it types gibberish.
But with enough time, eventually
it will write the first acts of Hamlet.
And with even more time, the complete works of
Eminem.
If ink in our universe glass generates any
random arrangements of particles, what could they be?
Well, a spontaneous fluctuation could give rise to a planet.
Or to a galaxy. Or even
to a lot of them. So maybe our universe has
already ended and all we see around us is
a “pop-up universe” – not a universe
that evolved from a Big Bang, but one that
fluctuated into existence by pure chance.
And that, like the drop of ink, will only
exist for a while before dissolving again.
Being random, pop-up universes could be similar
to ours but with funny glitches.
In some of these universes dinosaurs are riding snails.
In another, stars are made of blueberries.
In another you are wearing a funny hat.
Scientists in such universes wouldn't understand
those glitches, so maybe the greatest mysteries
of physics are just nonsense bugs
of our pop-up universe.
But not all possible fluctuations of our dead universe
have the same probability of occurring.
Smaller fluctuations are much more probable
than bigger ones. A planet is more likely
than a galaxy.
But you know what is even way more likely?
A human brain.
Are you actually just a brain?
You think, therefore you exist.
But what else do you truly know?
In the end, your brain is just interpreting
signals from your senses
and creating a world that you experience.
So technically, you could be just your brain
that thinks the world is real. And if we follow
the logic of the ink in the universe glass,
in particular, you could be a disembodied
brain that, just by chance, emerged in a dead
universe with your complete set of knowledge
and memories.
This is a pretty bizarre idea but if we do
the math, it is kind of pretty solid. Let’s
compare the number of brains inside bodies
in a living universe with the number of naked
brains in a dead universe.
Let’s go really big and imagine that a total
of 100 quadrillion humans will live around Earth.
And that the same amount of people
will live around every star in the universe.
If we add this together we get about 10 to the power of 41
brains inside bodies that will exist.
However, in a dead universe that has had enough
time to explore all possible fluctuations
and that will exist forever, the number of
naked brains that would emerge is well…
infinite.
So the probability that you are a floating brain
is not only vastly larger than the probability
that you are a real human. It is so inconceivably larger
that we can’t even meaningfully quantify
the difference. How do you compare a number
to infinity?
So… are you a floating brain that exists
for one moment in time, then basically forever
passes and then you exist for another moment in time?
Maybe not even in that order? Maybe
your life happens backwards and you just don't notice?
Maybe you have lived trillions of times already.
Are you the dream of a dead universe?
Really? Like, really?
Well, probably not. First of all, there are
a few loopholes. For example, dark energy
could behave completely differently from what
we think today and lead us to another future.
Or maybe our dead universe will be too motionless
to allow the creation of brains, even with
infinite time... Or maybe the universe will
end up dying in another way.
Our understanding of the cosmos doesn't have a solid enough
foundation for anyone to worry
if they are real or not.
Loopholes aside, if you were a fluctuating brain,
all the laws of physics stored in your
brain would have originated at random and
shouldn’t bear any relation to the real
world. But we just used those laws to prove
that you are a floating brain! So even if
you believe that you are a floating brain,
you’d have to admit that you have no good
reason to believe that you are actually
a floating brain.
Ok. So this hallucinatory trip might teach
us something about our theories about the
universe. But in the end it is just a really
weird exercise in what you can do with physics.
An exercise of what brains in bodies are able to think about.
So don’t worry – you are not a dream of the dead universe. Probably.
At kurzgesagt we love discussing topics like
Boltzmann brains because we’re convinced
that taking science and philosophy seriously
is really important for having a positive
impact on the world.
We’re lucky because this is our job – doing
something impactful we also enjoy
If you’re also aiming to make a positive difference,
where should you start? Well, we’ve noticed
a lot of advice about having a positive impact
isn’t based on the best available evidence.
Today’s sponsor, 80,000 Hours, aims to offer
some that is.
80,000 Hours is a a nonprofit career advice
organisation that wants to help people find
fulfilling careers that also do a lot of good
in the world – and their advice is free
to read online, without any hidden cost or
fee later on.
They’ve spent the last decade compiling
and conducting research into topics like,
"how much impact can one person actually
have" and "what are the best ways to make
a positive difference on important global
issues". And, like us, they care a lot about
making sure their work is based on the best
available evidence and consultation with experts.
You can read their main takeaways and actionable
advice in their free online career guide,
that's recently got a massive update for 2023.
If you’d like to read it for yourself and
start working towards a career that is both
meaningful and helps solve one of the world’s
most pressing problems, then you can find
it all completely free at 800000hours.org/kurzgesagt.